dieudonné bonsoir bonsoir j'ai donné ici
depuis un an vous ne figure y ait plus
sur les enquêtes d'opinion consacrée à
l'élection présidentielle le dernier
sondage en date il y a un an selon un
sondage ifop express vous donner 4 % ce
qui est beaucoup plus que beru ma delà
faut bien le dire
et aujourd'hui vous êtes à combien de
varrault sondage vous six et demi pour
cent
6 et 10% le star nom de travail très
intéressant j'ai appris beaucoup vous en
parler au passé parce que vous arrêtez
là en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
suite à une petite campagne de
diffamation j'ai commencé c'était pas
une stratégie personnelle d'apparaître
comme un anti blanc anti chrétien
antisémite
weekes la république il ya mieux comme
argument s'il me manquait six banques et
la casquette de pédophilie et de
cannibales ou là j'étais sur un segment
guider tout ce qu'on met et break up aux
signatures se rouler
vous arrêtez vraiment non alors ce qu'il
s'est passé c'est que par rapport aux
signatures nous les avions au 1er
février puis suite à cette campagne là
ça a été très très dur et l'a donc
toutes nos signatures il y en a eu 180
rétractation ce qui fait que la n 10
juin on pourra pas donc on va on va
faire autrement mais on reste on est je
ne serai pas candidat à ces élections
présidentielles vous retrouvez un petit
peu dans la même situation que le pen
d'une certaine façon quelque part tout à
fait le même pari avec ça me ferait
plaisir d'abord est ce que vous trouvez
normal qu'un mec comme vous qui fait 6
et demi pourcent faisait pas le droit de
vous présenter à cause des rétractations
sur les 500 signatures
bah oui je pense que c'est un jeu voilà
a truqué moi j'ai appris je me suis
confronté c'est une expérience
personnelle je vous encourage à le faire
ce serait que bon on vit un peu du
malaise social quand on est un comique
et puis c'est vrai que se mouiller un
peu aller sur le terrain voir ce qui se
passe c'est quand même intéressant est
ce que vous trouvez normal que le pen
qui représente 11 % du corps électoral
n'arrive pas à trouver ses 500
signatures
vous écouterez sa démocratique le fait
qu' il soit là parce que déjà il ya eu
des arrangements avant bons qu'ils
soient plus là parce qu'ils aient
d'autres arrangements c'est là la
démocratie ça veut pas dire grand chose
car on est dans un projet démocratique
on évoquera ci parce que moi je soutiens
pas du tout le pen gens pensent pis que
pendre mais un mec qui fait 11 % du
corps électoral c'est quand même bizarre
qu'il ait pas droit de se présenter aux
élections quand même ça te côté sympa
comme ça ce que le vasson une claudia
c'est vrai mais on est aussi est-ce que
le premier tour est utile aujourd'hui
qu'on nous vend et on a presque quel est
l'intérêt de nos produits tour
d'ailleurs là il ya pas mal de jeunes
qui s'étaient inscrits qui voulait me
donner la leur vote qu'ils m'ont qui
m'ont naturellement envoyer leur carte
d'électeur quand ils ont appris que je
n'étais pas crispé pour vous ils vont
voter blanc baisse est possible non mais
quelque part oui un semblant de jeu de
mots parce que noir mat wade
paris tient normalement il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté mais en même temps j'aime
les filles parce que je me sens un petit
peu le sens quimper siffleur persifleur
oui donc oui donc il ya une partie quand
même des gens qui n'hésitait pas envoyez
moi votre vos cartes d'électeur si vous
pensez que effectivement le fait plus on
poema rassemble on va faire un gros tas
de cartes d'électeurs et puis entre les
deux tours j'irai un petit peu leur
mettre la pression ou le feu ou le feu
oui pourquoi pas enfin le feu bon faut
faire un petit peu attention parce qu'il
ya des débats après en fait il ya la
justice j'ai vu pas mal de tête à un
procès j'ai été relaxé
donc je suis tout à fait pour moi je
peux parler avec lui été relaxé
j'étais accusé d'être raciste anti blanc
anti catholique ce qui est un peu gênant
dans ce pays ces trois clientèles c'est
vrai qu'on se couche quand même une
certaine partie du public
donc ça y est je peux discuter je veux
dire je suis tout à fait social
je suis parfaitement civilisé je fais où
je faisais ma gueule terminer devant la
misère du monde va maintenant j'ai
décidé d'être 3 tout à fait responsable
sur le service public
je suis un citoyen comme les autres
alors une lettre d' insulte alors
délectation mesdames messieurs comme
s'il en pleuvait j'en suis bien comme
inès avait gagné 0 1
c'est sa vie des gens grâce aux racistes
y en a d'ailleurs kim a déjà répondu il
m'a dit je viens d'acheter le bouquin
j'ai reconnu ma lettre être le [ __ ]
d'un [ __ ] c'est quand même un comble
sage pourtant volume numéro deux que je
t'emmerde je t'encule cher monsieur je
suis un de vos congés duire actuelle
néanmoins je voulais vous dire qu'il ya
au moins 25% de vrais français prêt à
temps cumulé avec un manche de pioche ne
pas se salir le sexe dans le cul d'une
merde de [ __ ] comme son héritier c'est
moi
2 be there qui dort avec me connais pas
ce qui c'est là qu'elle a un mouvement
catholique parisien monsieur dieudonné
nous respectons les juifs et des bus
support des france vous méprisez les
catholiques alors tant pis nous allons
décider ne veut plus dire et votre
théâtre de la main d'or
bon courage superbe ça c'est un mec
normalement il aurait dû être publié
bien avant moi il y en a tellement si
vous voulez ce qui peut-être une ça ça
c'est ça ce sont des des tracts qui ont
été posées sur les pare-brise des
voitures à l'entrée du spectacle j'étais
en tournée et donc il ya eu un mouvement
quand même si ces niveaux il faut faire
quelque chose car cet homme est
dangereux
donc ils ont eu un projet visant à
minimiser un petit peu du champ visuel à
la honte aux français qui iront
applaudir lettres abject qui recevra
leur argent pour cracher sur la france
et les chrétiens récemment condamné pour
racisme anti français et anti chrétiens
par monsieur je précise
j'ai été relaxé à 7 cette décision de
justice elle n'est plus n'est plus en
couple mais c'est vrai que à un moment
donné j'étais le raciste anti-blanc là
je ne cache pas que là c'était dans la
propre famille ma mère et j'ai cassé
minutes parce que j'ai aussi désertique
j'ai eu une page entière dans minute
c'est bien dieudonné se prend pour
nelson mandela c'est vrai que c'est
amusant d'avoir son nom à côté de celui
de mon père pour moi c'est évident c'est
la seule chose qui m'amuse
après il ya des trucs pas y développe
c'est ça qui est amusant c'est que là on
a affaire quand même un des théoriciens
ce sont des gens qui ont pignon sur rue
donc ils font autorité
alors là ils disent il ya deux types d'
indigènes le premier blanc il a inventé
à peu près tout ce qui existe sur la
terre à l'exception du tam tam et des
maraboutage
mais ces bergers laisse il est submergé
par des barbares a faim celui ci peut et
doit crever ainsi va la vie le second et
coloré il est généralement à une colo
l'arrière et le whisky étant le seul
élément de modernité qui est attiré son
attention
il lui en pagne sénat doit être sauvée
c'est un peu comme si à la naissance on
supprimait le bébé de mieux fortifier le
mieux portants et le plus vif et que
l'on sélectionné que les crevettes
rachitique
non mais c'est vrai ça ouais ouais bah c
c'est dans ces temps minute bon écrivez
moi pour un volume de numéros 2010
la demi-lieue alors
n'est plus candidat mais de nous
l'annoncer ce soir en exclusivité
exclusivité
donc je ne suis pas candidat mais je
récupère envoyez moi donc à bobino
invoqué des lecteurs nous allons
ramasser le plus possible pour l'heure
alors peut-être pas leur [ __ ] dans le
q qu'est-ce que je te sens mais
éventuellement leur mettre un gros un
gros axe de pression entre les deux
tours je pense que ça peut être marrant
plus haut plus on en aura lieu ce sera
donc envoyé l'onuci ou à l'euro à bobino
à bobino vous êtes à bobino dans un
spectacle qui s'appelle cocorico c'est
l'histoire d'un mec qui se présente à la
présidentielle et qui parle des gens qui
le côtoie toute la journée et tout un
tas de personnages comme c'est une
espèce de galerie de portraits tous les
soirs à 20h30
pour l'instant on n'a pas eu de problème
aux yeux
j'en ai retenu une fois le spectacle de
théâtre a été bombés mais c'est fini
c'est terminé
c'était de l'époque où j'étais candidat
évidemment à rémy avait quelques
pressions des petits prix c'est fini
tout ça
dieudonné on va parler du scandale alors
le seconde les vandales
oui c'est une vraie accablement vous
expliquer sur une chaîne de télévision
hertziennes si j'ai fait comme connerie
en pointe alors dans lyon capitale vous
avez commencé par déclarer
l'antisémitisme n'existe pas parce que
toute façon le juif n'existe pas pour
moi c'est une secte c'est une
escroquerie
ça n'existe pas pour moi catholiques
juifs musulmans ça n'existe pas
l'humanité est une et indivisible
il ya l'humanité qui est une et
indivisible ya l'individu entre eux
entre les deux il ya tout un tas de sous
groupes chez ceux qui aiment le jazz la
soupe aux choux qui ce qu'ils sentent
musulmans juifs mais moi c'est pour moi
ça n'existe pas tout ça pour moi il ya
l'humanité une et indivisible et je me
refuse de voir dans le regard de l'autre
autre chose qu'un humain et ça ne
m'intéresse pas donc j'ai le droit quand
même en tant que citoyens de ne pas
reconnaître l'appartenance religieuse où
je m'en fous que cette pour moi ça
n'existe pas alors j'ai dû je dors je
réclamais ce alors les ont ciblé
uniquement sur la catégorie juive alors
j'avais déjà des problèmes avec les
chrétiens j'étais anti-blanc la ville
antisémite feu des jets d'eau faut dire
que vous avez déclaré aussi l'apartheid
en israël c'est un fait oui ça je pense
qu'effectivement je pense que
aujourd'hui et c'est justement à cause
de ces un repli communautariste dire que
les communautés aujourd'hui sont de plus
en plus refermée sur elle même
je le vois parler par ce type de
réaction normalement en temps normal
ouais un homme un citoyen a le droit de
dire ce qu'ils pensent si je suis anti
communautariste j'ai quand même le droit
de le dire j'étais à fait là priori on
n'a pas le droit de le dire ou de le
penser sur certaines personnes et puis
par rapport à ce qui se passe en israël
je pense qu'effectivement les
palestiniens vivent une agression
terrible j'ai le droit de penser alors
dans actualité juive vous vous rétracter
pas vous enfoncer le clou là vraiment
vous il ya des forces et actualité juive
quand même il a volé jour suivent ne
peut pas pour moi déterminer un peuple
sur vous dit les juifs c'est des sémites
et puis voilà comme l'est comme les
persiste dans votre émission à penser
que j'ai le droit en tant que citoyen de
cette planète de ne pas voir chez autrui
autre chose qu'un être humain et je m'en
fous de savoir la couleur de ses
chaussettes et pour moi d'être juif ou
la couleur de ses chaussettes c'est la
même chose alors vous dites juif c'est
un concept virtuel qui n'a plus de
raison d'être
alors juifs comme catholiques comme
musulmans comme je sais pas pourquoi on
parle plus d actualité juive peut-être
parce qu'ils étaient plus concernés par
le problème c'est normal ouais enfin
j'ai trouvé quand même étrange que après
leurs propos soient repris par exemple
dans le monde
dans libération sans même me téléphoner
ça arrive oui oui mais c'est étrange
parce que je veux dire c'est quand même
un magazine religieux et je vois pas en
quoi il fera autorité sur le sujet quoi
on peut au moins là l'objectivité des
journalistes c'est de savoir un petit
peu ce que je pense et ce que je suis en
train de vous dire je le sais ce que
j'ai dit à cette journaliste qui m'a dit
mais monsieur et vous vous ennuyez notre
existence j'ai dit je ne lis pas je vous
êtes ma soeur ma dîme à ce moment-là
noir cela n'existe pas elle m'a dit je
dis bien on évitera des grands problèmes
si noir n'existe pas dans le même numéro
d' actualité juive elie semoun dit
dieudonné devient un le pen de gauche
mais oui j'ai vu les lits et en photo à
côté du maire de paris
il a sa carrière aussi il a ses intérêts
et puis certainement c'est messi reste
mon pote puisqu'en bon je pense que là
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt l'occasion
m'envoyer d'un petit clin d'oeil
à sa sauce quoi pour me dire dieudo
pensa - appel - de temps en temps alors
le bouquet final c'est l'écho des
savanes
vous dites je préfère le charisme de ben
laden à celui de george bush
bush incarne le mal absolu il serait
capable de faire sauter ses propres tour
pour gagner du pétrole mais je parlais
de charisme et de personnages bien c'est
ce qui m'a marqué et je pensais et je
pense et je continue à penser
qu'effectivement il avait plus de
charisme mais je pense que dans cette
aventure il a il s'étonne c'est un staff
est grand et que et que george bush
moi je pense que c'est un homme
dangereux berlusconi bout je pense que
ce sont des gens dangereux pour la pour
la planète le journal du dimanche je
vous dit elie semoun m'a appelé pour me
dire que je me suis pas fait que des
copains et que je suis pas prêt de faire
du cinéma
dire que vous sous-entendez dans cette
interview au journal du dimanche que
finalement il y aurait comme ça un lobby
qui vous interdire est de faire du
cinéma
vous dites il ya une pétition contre moi
qui a été signé par gad elmaleh elie
semoun et arthur chez lui ai dit au
téléphone c'est ce qui m'a dit alors
maintenant à savoir qui est juif et qui
ne l'est pas dans cette profession je me
suis jamais posé la question mais s'ils
me le dit c'est qu'il doit y avoir il
doit y avoir aussi une raison peut-être
que c'est pour titiller mais alors il
devrait être un peu plus méfiant parce
que moi je parle je dis ce que j'entends
et je pense pas que ça serve les
intérêts de quiconque que de parler de
cette façon là et et puis bon je sais
qu'il n'ya pas de lobby noir ça je le
sais je peux vous en parler
non le reste je ne sais pas il vous a
dit t'es pas prêt de faire du cinéma
il m'a dit ça il y là tu t'es pas fait
des amis il a mon avis tu es grillé
alors je suis venu faire votre émission
donc déjà il n'a pas tout à fait raison
pas griller par tous si tout le monde
peut s'exprimer c'est ce qui fait le
charme de cette émission
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus